let's talk about you spend a lot of your
time thinking about time let's set the
stage with turn back the clock a little
bit set the scene for us and explain how
Einstein decided to get involved with
concepts of time right so like all of us
sunstone lay awake at night as a
teenager wrestling with the problem you
know what is time my my favorite
definition is time is just one damn
thing after or not but he came to
realize that there was a conflict a deep
conflict in physics and we're talking
about the turn of the 20th century deep
conflict in physics between two things
one of which is very familiar so you
must have had the experience of sitting
in a railway carriage and you think oh
we're moving off and it's a train on the
parallel track going the other way
that's often called the principle of
relativity that uniform motion is
relative you're familiar with it as well
I don't know whoever had this experience
a lot of people are afraid of flying I
do a lot of flying some I'm not afraid
but the one thing that happens to me
almost inevitably as the plane taxis out
to take off I fall asleep just happens
almost every time so then when I wake up
I have no idea whether we're airborne or
still on the runway and that's because
smooth flight you can't tell you can
drink your coffee and you know play
marbles or whatever same laws of physics
so that's been then since the time of
Galileo that the laws of mechanics are
relative there's no that you can talk
about my speed relative to you but
nobody's got an absolute speed so that
was already known and but this was in
conflict with what had been discovered
in the 19th century about the weight of
the light behave so light so an
electromagnetic wave and the equations
for electromagnetism all worked out in
the 1850s by James Clark Maxwell and
from the mathematics of those equations
where I'm not going to go into that but
from the mathematics of those equations
it was clear that the speed of light is
supposed to be a fixed number constant
well how can you reconcile the
relativity of motion with a constant
speed of light because
what happens if you chase after a light
beam can you overtake the light you know
or if I chase after that is coming at
you surely you'll encounter the lighter
the higher speed than if you dashing
away from it and he realized these two
pillars of physics couldn't both be
correct and the only way to reconcile
them was to do something funny with time
and space as well as it happens we're
going to just talk about time basically
in daily life we think that time and
space are just sort of there is an arena
in which the great drama of nature is
acted out but what Einstein said is know
that the these says that space and time
are part of the cast their part of
nature just like matter can be changed
manipulated so space and time can be
changed on manipulated it's often called
warping time or time dilation so you had
this idea that your time and my time
might not be the same if we're moving
differently and well I demonstrate it
right away but we can we can introduce a
time difference just by me walking on
them that's all it takes now you might
say that that must be a trivial amount
it's true but if I took a plane as I'm
going to a lunch on Monday it's a London
and then come back again and we compare
your clock and my clock if they're good
clocks we see there's a difference
because we've been moving differently
and then interest the movement changes
but you ask the movement but because
light is the key to this to get a really
big time warp you need to move it close
to the speed of light and in effect what
you are doing if you zoom off for close
to the speed of light is you are leaping
into the future quicker so it's a sort
of time travel into the future it means
you can get to a future event faster so
you fancy living to the year 3000 or
here on earth well you can either do it
the slow way and sit here for a thousand
years or you zoom off close to the speed
of light and get to the year 3000 then
say one year so what it means is that
the interval of time between two fixed
events can depend on the way you move so
time is not absolute its relative as we
say you also realize the gravity does
funny things to time time we're going to
get into this later runs and I don't
think time runs it
but i'll use the words for now time runs
a little bit faster up on the roof than
it does in the basement once again this
is a measurable effect we're going to
talk later on how you measure these
effects so in other words tight you know
time is something that depends on how
you're moving and what your situation is